vuelvo en la región
bueno pues en primer lugar tenemos que
empezar por los los problemas que se han
dado con pakistán no por ejemplo
pakistán siempre tuvo un gps planeó la
sombra de la empresa paquistaní en la
región afgana teniendo sobre todo todo
lo que era el movimiento irredentista de
los bastones paquistaníes que hasta
cierto punto también los talibanes a
través de la idea del pastunistán habían
pues habían ido también coqueteando con
esa idea una idea de expansión
nacionalista para crear la gran
afganistán y eso generó pues que
pakistán se viera realmente pues muy
preocupada por ese por el auge de auto
imposible para mí es tan fuerte no de
ahí que siempre haya estado influyendo
el problema es que ahora mismo al
existir un emirato islámico
bajo una fuerte influencia paquistaní
durante muchos años ahora claro se han
emancipado tienen el poder controló un
país y ahora se están dando diferentes
problemas diferentes tensiones con el
vecino pakistán sobre todo con
cuestiones de inmigración y sobre todo
con el trato de la minoría past pastún
dentro de pakistán eso por un lado por
otro lado también china tiene frontera
con afganistán una frontera muy chiquita
en la región
nororiental y los chinos por ejemplo lo
que no quieren es que organizar se
convierta en un santuario de yihadistas
que puedan
generar un movimiento yihadista un
movimiento terrorista dentro de lo que
es la región del xinjiang en famoso
turkestán occidental perdón turkestán
oriental que forma parte de china y casi
que ha sido de testigos bueno pues del
auge de una insurgencia yihadista muy
importante